Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute
Papers with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Today we are going to have a look at how
this new paper just supercharged AI-driven
image generation. For instance, you will see
that it can do this, and this, and even this.
And today, it also seems clearer and
clearer that we are entering the age
of AI-driven image generation. You see,
these new learning-based methods can do
something that previously was only possible
in science-fiction movies. And that is,
we enter what we wish to see, and
the AI paints an image for us.
Last year, this image was possible,
this year this image is possible.
That is incredible progress in just one
year. So, I wonder what is the next step?
Beyond the regular quality increases,
how else could we improve these systems?
Well, scientists at Google had
a fantastic idea. In this paper,
they promise prompt to prompt editing. What
is that? What problem does this solve? Well,
whenever we create an image, and
we feel mostly satisfied with it,
but we would need to add just a little change
to it, we cannot easily do that. But now,
have a look at 5 of my favorites examples
of doing exactly this with this new method.
One, if we create this imaginary cat riding
a bike, and we are happy with this concept,
but after taking some driving lessons, our
little imaginary cat wishes to get a car now,
well, now it is possible. Just change the prompt,
and get the same image with minimal modifications
to satisfy the changes we have made. I love
it. Interestingly, it has also become a bit
of a chonker in the process. A testament to
how healthy it is to ride the bike instead!
And two, if we are yearning for bigger
changes, we can use a photo, and change
its style as if it were painted by a child.
And I have to say this one is very convincing.
Three, and now, hold on to your papers and behold
the Cake Generator AI. Previously, if we created
this lemon cake, and wished to create other
variants of it, for instance, a cheese cake,
or apple cake, we got a completely different
result. These variants don’t have a great deal
to do with the original photo. And, I wonder would
it be possible with the new technique that? Oh my
goodness. Yes! Look at that. These cakes are not
only delicious, but, they are also real variants
of the original slice. Yum! This is fantastic. So,
AI-generated cuisine, huh? Sign me up right now!
Four, after generating a car at the side of
the street, we can even say how we wish to
change the car itself. For instance, let’s
make it a sports car instead. Great. Or,
if we are happy with the original car, we can
also ask the new AI to leave the car intact,
and change it surroundings instead. Let’s
put it on a flooded street, or, quickly,
before water damage happens, put it in
Manhattan instead. Excellent. Loving it.
Now, of course, you see that not even this
technique is perfect, the car still has changed
a little, but that is something that will surely
be addressed a couple more papers down the line.
Five, we can even engage in mask-based
editing. If we feel that this beautiful
cat also deserves a beautiful shirt, we
can delete this part of the screen, then,
the AI will start from a piece of noise
and morph it until it becomes a shirt.
How cool is that? So good! It works for
many different kinds of apparel too.
And while we marvel at some
more of these amazing examples,
I would like to tell you one more
thing that I loved about this paper.
And that is, it describes a general
concept. Why is this super cool? Well,
it is super cool because it can be applied
to different image generators. If you look
carefully here, you see that this concept
was applied to Google’s own closed solution,
Imagen here. And I hope you know what’s coming
now. Oh yes, a free and open-source text to
image image synthesizer is also available and it
goes by the name Stable Diffusion. We celebrated
it coming into existence a few episodes ago.
But, why am I so excited about this? Well,
with Stable Diffusion, we can finally take out our
digital wrench and tinker with it. For instance,
we can now adjust the internal parameters
in ways that we cannot do with the closed
solutions like DALL-E 2 and Imagen. So
let’s have a look at why that matters.
Do you see the prompts here? Of course
you do. Now, what else do you see?
Parameters! Yes, this means
that the hood is popped open,
we can not only look into the inner workings of
the AI, but we can also play with them, and thus,
these results become reproducible at home. So
much so that there is already an unofficial,
open-source implementation of this new
technique applied to Stable Diffusion.
Both of these are free for everyone to run.
I am loving this. What a time to be alive!
And once again, this showcases the power of the
papers, and the power of the community. The links
are available in the video description,
and for now, let the experiments begin!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!